Okay,
we are live. Hello, folks.
Lot to do today. Um, I'm also trying
Gemini here. I've been messing with a
couple of these models.
I don't necessarily think that the
quality is going to really matter
between them. I think they're all kind
of interchangeable. It's just the
difference in the the um
uh the little UIs and the integrations
and then um pricing and token speed and
also who you're paying money to.
Uh, okay. Yeah. So, this is a problem.
This run is just bad.
Oh, but we have Spencer's PR. We can
merge.
Let's do that real quick.
No syntax highlighting here is kind of
annoying.
The only change to this
uh is the C. So, we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
I've already checked this
last night.
Okay. Conflicts.
Uh, let's fix those here.
It's weird. I feel like this great calm.
I'm exhausted.
This is the last day for the release,
but I feel calm.
Really not a big fan of this diff
format.
Okay. So, actually he didn't really do
that much here. He just did this.
Let me see. So, we need both of these, I
believe.
Okay,
now I can do this merge.
implementing
Dr. Daario. Mario Dr. Mario said the
port would take five minutes. Yeah, it
will take five minutes.
Hey, Vault. Haven't checked remote in a
couple of days. Lots of cleanup, lots of
polish. Uh goal is release on Monday.
like soft start like soft releasing
tomorrow or today. We'll release Monday
with announcements, blogs all week, fix
anything that's on fire, but otherwise I
need some days off. Um, to give you an
idea,
I lost my coffee this morning. I looked
everywhere around here. It took me five
minutes to realize that I had left it in
the microwave.
So, I am out at the moment, but this
release kicks ass. So, that's something.
Puffer is a very cool library. Got
started with RL and always thought it
was unbearably slow when using stuff
like gym. Have you seen the latest? Oh
man, do I have a treat for you.
All right.
Build breakout. Puffer train breakout.
It's trained.
That's a full solve. 4 seconds.
And nish, my girlfriend works just as
hard.
It doesn't show the full diffs until you
approve it, which I really don't like.
Stop pumping chip prices. I'd be
grateful. Yeah.
Um,
why do you have a list with people on
you don't like on X?
Uh, there's some guy that made it where
apparently you can get them out of your
um apparently it removes them from the
timeline if they're on a separate list.
There's like a thing you can do with it.
I probably should just try the open code
thing or one of those routers cuz then I
don't have to keep using these
absolutely
dog [ __ ] terminal apps from all these
companies.
Every single one of them is stupid in
some way or another.
But the thing is, uh, I'm pretty sure
the that the bigger labs, they have
their models tuned, um, for their own
their own CLI, you know, they have their
own harness [ __ ] So, I think you
actually degrade the models doing that.
So, I've been using the native ones for
each of them.
I actually, it was funny. So, I was
trying to see, hm, can I replace Claude
with something because I'm sick of
giving anthropic money. And
so, the Google one is a pain in the ass
here because I can't figure out a
reasonable way to set up prepaid
billing, which is pretty bad. And um the
Open AI one, there's literally not even
a way to require it to approve per
change. Like it says that there's one in
the docs, but it just straight up
doesn't exist.
So, they're not free vault. Um, I think
Enthropic maybe has one as well. Um,
they uh they get the right to use your
company logo or your project logo on
their web page.
already going the wrong way.
So, yes and no. Jamorphy, I tried that
with So, I tried Cabbrris. Um, I tried
Cerabus with GLM because it's really,
really fast. It's kind of a dumb model,
but it's really fast. The model is too
dumb to even be useful, unfortunately.
And also their pricing is insanely high.
So like even if you are in complete
control like here, what is this thing
doing here? This is basically applying
the exact same template operation to 20
different things.
Like
I could do this drunk if I had to,
right, manually, but it would take
several hours.
Uh,
our shop got 10k
5k credits from Open AI. They want to
hook users. Yeah,
you enjoy the Chinese models.
But I wasn't doing it because it was the
Chinese model coder. It was because of
the Sarah Brress hardware.
Um, Cerus is a really awesome company.
Local models are reliable for small
refactors. Uh, I don't think so.
Realistically, I think that if people
were actually trying, then it would work
by now. But I don't think people are
trying as hard as they are to just like
win the baselines, win the benchmarks.
though. I do wonder is there um is there
like a good updated model size versus
performance chart? That would be kind of
nice to have.
I guess it would also have to take into
account quantization and Enough.
gotten a tad bit LM builds in the sense
that they are useful tools um for like
doing like operations faster like sure
in the sense that oh there's no more
programmers they're so smart the people
are human like go [ __ ] yourself
scammers
Quen 27 bill
both kind of good for their size. Are
those actually usable for anything?
Hey, Lance.
And then run some basic small refactors.
Some issues. That's good to hear.
Kimmy would take 860 gigs at FP8.
What's GLM47
or GLM5
744?
So GLM5 is 40 bill active for RAMs, but
you still have to keep it in RAM, don't
you?
Yeah, that's kind of rough.
Is there actually an efficient way to
serve? Aren't they awful for um for VRAM
or am I wrong there?
Apparently we uh we just smashed go with
the latest sweep.
didn't catch the lives for some time.
Lance, this is the last day after over
900 hours of stream dev. This is the
last day of dev for 40.
I'm completely exhausted. I've got
nothing left. I look fine, but mentally
it's like cuckoo.
going live or taking a vacation. Um,
so next, uh, it'll launch Monday
and that's for stream viewers only to
know, but uh, it'll launch Monday. We
have some articles that'll release
throughout the week. People on stream
have already seen them. They haven't
read them fully, but they've seen them
roughly. I've been writing them on
stream. Uh, hopefully nothing is on
fire. I can't guarantee it because
brain's fried, but we got a Docker. A
Docker should at least work.
And then I'm taking a few days off.
I'm going to lift weights, listen to my
book, and play some chill games. And
that's literally it until I can think
again.
a few months old. Does it still have
PyTorch?
Does the new Puffer 4 is 5,000 lines of
CUDA?
It actually won't take time at all to
upgrade MS. The upgrade from an N from
3.0 to 4.0 takes 5 minutes.
Oh, there we go. Wait,
Gemini,
why can nobody figure out how to make
the terminal scrolling work?
Google, you're supposed to be able to
build [ __ ] That's awful. Look at the
flashy, stupid terminal scrolling.
didn't start to [ __ ] around trying to
min migrate when I show you reinvented
the wheel. I did not reinvent the wheel,
Lance. Uh, we get full deterministic
training, Perf improvements, way cleaner
profiles.
Uh, what else do we get? Oh, and we get
stable Bflat 16. None of those work with
torque.
wouldn't use it for coding. Well, I'm
sick of giving money to Anthropic, so I
decided to try this.
And Codeex literally doesn't have a mode
for uh that lets you see changes as
they're being applied. So, [ __ ] that.
This at least has one. It's just that
the UI is a little bugged,
but I didn't. No, I didn't. Cuz Lance, I
didn't write my own torch. So, that's
not reinventing the wheel because I
didn't try to make torch but better.
There we go.
This is better. Now I actually can see
reasonable amounts of stuff.
Oops. Hang on. I got somebody at my
door.
I doing here? They're showing the app.
Yeah, they're not getting me to use
their stupid app.
Um, I might be able to do that for you
today. Yes, Jess.
So, unless it's bugged, apparently Go is
just smashed with um versus the dumb
opponent, but still smashed.
We will say
copy over since it's all HTML.
It should be
I actually haven't ported the articles
to the site yet. I need to do that.
apparently works on 19 by9 though. Jess
Puffer V5 machine code
modify my Rust financial engines reload
the observations of the data set server
directly in the GPU. Turns out the end
was a bottleneck. Well, look, you can't
possibly complain that I made puffer so
fast that now your end code is too slow,
right?
I mean, maybe if you'd just written it
in C, it would have been fast enough.
Who knows, right?
I really just don't get it. I am a
simple man. I like my C.
Yeah, it's all right, Lance. We actually
have to do that with a bunch of our
environments now cuz now the training is
so fast. Like mobile, which we thought
was a hard environment. We solved it
with less than 100k parameters in 10
seconds.
So
buffer kind of good.
Maybe you've turned off all the features
that make Rust Rust faster.
The thing I don't like about Rust is it
puts the safety features into the
language rather than than into compiler
options.
Well, look, let's have a call after
release. I'd love to help out. You
convince me. But you can use Rust if you
want to be fair. It's like you can
definitely make stuff fast out of that.
Um, I just don't think it gives you
anything over C and it gets in your way,
but like you can totally make stuff fast
in Rust. I'm just being pedantic.
But yeah, if you want to do uh something
professional with us after release,
absolutely.
We got a couple finance clients at the
moment. I know people uh are doing RL in
this space.
Or if you just want to have a friendly
chat over ports, that's fine as well.
No pressures.
We're chilling.
Rust fans talk about how fast Rust is.
It's literally just turning off. Yeah,
that's the thing. You end up back
basically at C if you turn all the
features off.
Help and puffer.
Okay. Yeah, that's good. We're uh we're
definitely down for that.
If you guys want to get some uh insider
information for your stuff and you're
looking to contribute to the project,
that's cool, too.
I guess it's the paranoid language.
In my mind, though, it's like the
complexity of it bothers me, right?
because like you're trading off some of
your understanding of the code at a
glance for hopes that the compiler is
catching bugs for you. Whereas when I'm
reading simple C code, it's so much
easier for me to just tell exactly
what's going on. I will admit there's
definitely some jank stuff in C that's
dated. But like every time somebody
tries to make a modern C, they don't
actually fix the stuff that's jank with
C and they introduce a bunch of stuff
that you don't need.
Like realistically, the stuff that's
wrong with C is like there's a bunch of
code that does like that just should not
compile around un undefined behavior.
There's a bunch of jank stuff that
compilers do. Some stuff is
underspecified.
Um there's some compiler flags that
should error by default that aren't even
enabled and that don't cost anything.
Like it's a pretty small set of things.
Oh, okay. That's not what I meant by
insider information. I meant insider
information on the freaking RL
development. Obviously, I don't have
insider information on anything
financial.
Yes. Automatically clipped by the SEC's
clipping platform. Killer drones
dispatched to your door.
Yeah, maybe that's a sensitive uh topic
in that case.
Took a trip
while your president decides what to do.
Look, we're just going to need a overall
uh like just an overarching decree from
everybody within a thousand miles of
that place that there will be no [ __ ]
and then everything will be good.
Gemini, come on.
Google
Middle East and use puffer to solve the
conflict.
monetary policy. Uh Salesforce tried to
do that. It was very weird. I don't
think that they made very many friends
at Salesforce because they released a
paper basically arguing that they used
RL to show that they should pay more
taxes,
which was very weird.
But then they used really shitty like
metrics for it. And actually, it was
kind of funny that they they actually
sort of, if you actually read the paper,
they sort of disproved what they were
trying to say. And then the uh the free
market baseline
global
geopolitical supply chain siml
library I could use to solve it down the
line. You're looking at it. It's a
puffer lib.
Make it fast and run the puffer. You
know, puffer 5, we got a whole bunch of
algorithmic stuff. We're expecting like
2x better pf on the ends. not speed like
actual learning. That's going to be my
best guess.
raising getting funding in the EU is not
straightforward.
Oh, I didn't see that. That was Vault.
Yeah, Vault's pretty cool. Vault is
doing um Runescape things with Puffer.
Actually, the RSM is going to be super
super good for um
for the next research bits. It'll be
fun. I'm excited to play with it.
You did open a PR that has more code
than the entirety of Puffer, though, so
I'm going to have to look at that with
you after I'm back.
Literally more code than the entirety of
Puffer.
Uh, the a word is not a good word around
here, but I see what you're trying to
do.
What are we working on today? This is
the last day before release.
We just have to like fix up a bunch of
stale end um end binding code, ship all
the models, push the docs, blah blah
blah, and build the docker, whatever,
and we're done.
Yeah, that library is uh
not too good to say the least.
We got 5,000 lines of training code. I
think we're pretty minimal.
That's for all CUDA.
And actually it was only about one or
two thousand lines longer than the torch
back end if you wrote the thing in torch
um see or torch with custom kernels.
So it's basically free to replace torch
as it turns out.
UAE is close second.
USA man USA is pretty great. But I will
say, don't come to our cities.
All right? The US is great for suburbs
and rural spots, and you can actually
build companies from there.
And if you need to be near a city for
stuff, you be like half hour, 45 minutes
from a city,
not in the damn city.
How do I like for Gemini? I just been
trying it today, Lance. Mainly because
I'm sick of giving anthropic money.
Um, I don't know. It's okay so far.
We'll see.
Like seriously, a very very major fa uh
factor in me staying sane for this
release is I can turn this way and I
have like
I think they're pear trees. I've got
like white blossoming pear trees that
are just like raining petals all over
the place on a farm in the middle of
nowhere with no sound and no
disturbances and it's pretty nice. Went
for a little run this morning. Got some
fresh air.
Texas. Texas is good. Spencer's in
Texas.
Florida.
I'm a resident of Florida. It's okay.
I'm not in Florida now. I'm in Maryland.
The farm is good like I think eight or
nine months out of the year. Maybe maybe
like eight months out of the year. It
gets too hot in the summer and too cold
in the winter.
Well, I'm not actually doing the farm
work, Lance.
Price difference between Claude and
Gemini.
Uh, I actually don't know. I maybe
Gemini is a bit cheaper.
I don't I don't really know, though.
They say OMS autoate stupid webdev. No,
they don't really because the thing is,
okay, the thing is you shouldn't be
saying this thing is stupid. So
therefore, let me have this thing do the
stupid work. You should be asking why is
this thing stupid? Why can why are we
doing it this way? Can we do it in a way
that isn't stupid?
Like the webdev does not remotely suck
anywhere near as much
when you do this.
Like our site's just an HTML page.
So, it's kind of on web devs for making
their whole ecosystem [ __ ]
And the fact that they uh are now
saying, "Well, it's [ __ ] so we need
AI to do it." Like, that's just a
massive failing of thought.
west or east, east coast most of the
year. I spend a couple months in
California
in the summer usually.
I don't know whether I'll be there long
term though. I think most likely I just
be there for a few months out of the
year for the weather and for business.
Sounds good. Make sure that I think I
have you added because I don't the
requests on Discord suck. So like at me
or whatever if you don't get me there
risk sort of webdev
the supply chain risk sort. What's that
mean?
Oh, well that's just I mean that's again
their fault for having a billion
packages that they don't need,
right?
I mean the like you don't just stack up
failures that's a ton of [ __ ] and
then say well now I need an AI to deal
with the [ __ ] right? That's just
idiot.
Like I can't think of a stupider
possible way to do things than that.
Like if you actually think the AI is
smart, which it's not good enough to do
this, but if you're convinced that the
AI is smart, that's still not the right
way to do it. You'd have it rewrite the
whole stack like a hundredth of the size
and without all the [ __ ]
and not in [ __ ] TypeScript either.
Like come on.
But then again,
that's expecting conscious thought out
of web devs.
Probably a little too much.
good web stack then if not for
TypeScript.
Um,
HTML C and web assembly
and a little CSS.
Honestly, JavaScript is kind of ass.
Like, modern JavaScript especially
is just so bad.
Like our our website has a little bit of
JavaScript, but it's mostly it's HTML
and web assembly via C.
All the demos are web assembly. See,
we're going to have constellation on the
website, too. our whole dashboard and
everything super fast, super stable.
See,
Well, look, if people would do things
reasonably, I wouldn't have to be that
opinionated, right? I'd just be chilling
because stuff wouldn't suck. But then I
look around and it's like, that guy's
huffing paint. That guy's like
frantically eating crayons.
You know, I don't have to be doing this
stuff. If we could just have things be
sane and like actually have heck where
it needs to be and fix all our problems,
I'd be very happy just chilling here on
the farm. Lots of other stuff I could
do. I could just go read some physics. I
could study. Yeah, there's lots of fun
things I can do.
It does stuff so weirdly. Like I don't
know why it would do that with said
it's more so it's like I kind of see
where the world can be if stuff were
done competently.
He's not going to do it competently.
Guess I got to figure it out.
It's like there's this guy who posts gym
videos on YouTube and he's like, you
know, lifting his weights and then he
always has people in the background like
intentionally doing really stupid
exercises that make absolutely no sense.
That's basically the canvas that it
seems like when I look around. It's just
like, huh?
cuz we'll have to go look and see if
this matches the args. I don't think it
does, but we'll see. Maybe it does.
Last piece of software I was impressed
by.
This rocks
so much so that I sponsored it.
Ray rocks. This is awesome software.
Three to four engineers.
That's cool.
as a bias.
Is Rayb used to build the Ms? It's used
to render them for the most part.
Like all the rendering is done in Rayb.
A couple of the M's use like the ray
math functions, but really not very many
of them. It's mostly the rendering.
They have a couple nice
It got a couple nice things for
quitterians and stuff, but like really
those are pretty easy to implement.
The only thing that really really
matters is the rendering. Raib is really
good.
Okay. So, I forgot that that has a bias.
That has a bias.
SDL.
Um,
you could, but Rayb is just so nice,
man. Ray is still very low level. you
like I often have just raw uh raw
shaders and stuff with it, but it's just
so nice.
Like just go look at the cheat sheet
with Ray Lib and you'll see Bye.
I guess I can get it to check the
weights.
Why do you not use VS Code? Why do you
use VS Code?
What would that give me? Nothing.
It gives me nothing except a shitty
graphical application that I have to
then deal with over SSH and crap. I have
a full editor
right here
and it's much easier. There.
I actually don't know where the
discrepancy would be. We might have to
do this layer by layer sadly.
I do wonder actually. Do I have the
decoder bias?
Is that a real gem behind you?
I don't know. Let's go find out. We'll
see.
I mean, it's just a really good
background.
all those machines.
Uh, most of the big ones are actually
really cheap.
The
the big double tower there was like 2K.
I think the Smith was like two or three.
The servers cost more than the machines.
You see all the servers in the
background as well, right? That's where
we're running all the stuff for Puffer.
Oh, maybe you were referring to the
servers. I don't know. The gym machines
are the server machines.
I think we're going to have to match it
layer by layer.
I'll let it finish, but I think we're
going to have to match this layer by
layer.
rural area factor contracts.
Um I actually well to be fair I have not
spent any of the money from puffer. All
the puffer money stays in the puffer
account
It could be the alignment to be fair,
right?
I don't know if we're going to be able
to stick with this model.
You just type stuff and it just ignores
you and keeps doing whatever the [ __ ]
It's just doing the same [ __ ] again.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, that's [ __ ] dog [ __ ] isn't it?
Let's see if it'll pay attention to a
new request or not.
Which AI lab do you think has the best
RL? Definitely Puffer AI.
They're doing some really, really cool
stuff with small models. You can
actually try them and train them at home
on a ton of different tasks. And you can
get pretty damn near superhuman policies
in seconds.
And it's all completely free, funny
enough. I don't know how they do it.
And that's why you star the puffer on
GitHub. It's free and it helps us out a
ton.
It's pretty sad that it can't figure
this out.
This is unfortunately something that
would take quite a while to do manually.
So all it has to do for reference, it
has to just pull in the build commands
from um build.sh.
It has to load the policy up with the
CUDA and the C
and um then it has to check the weights,
just basically numeric test on the
weights to make sure they're loaded
correctly. And then the activation
buffers there. So this is what I needed.
Now it's actually going to do the full
build script. Good.
This is just pulling from build page.
Okay. So, it doesn't realize that it
doesn't need to port everything over
standalone like this, but fine.
This is throw this like this is all
throwaway code. This is all like we test
it, we fix the bug, we delete this.
That's fine.
Okay. It's having trouble with um
building the standalone and like getting
the imports. Fine. Whatever. Uh it can
burn some tokens and do that.
This is just a C versus um
C++ compile thing, right?
oil pipeline.
Well, this at the moment is more so
spelunking and fixing
broken crap for our demos.
Um, the only reason I'm putting time in
for this one is it's a really cool
policy and I'd like to have it on the
website.
Okay,
fair. So, what it did here is it's just
um it made a backup of Puffernet and
it's trying to resolve the syntax
differences with NVCC.
I actually don't know why the [ __ ] this
is. Um, in C it's valid to just calick
to void uh as void star and it auto cast
to your type for whatever reason. NVCC I
guess C++ it's Huh?
Page is funny. The best handle ever.
Dynamic web of page.
Still fighting imports it looks like.
Again, I'm fine with this because this
is all throwaway.
Um,
this is like all all throwaway. This
amount of stuff is not I have never
actually put this amount of stuff into
um the real puffer train code or
anything, but this is all throwaway
test.
Like once we find the discrepancy
between these two nets and fix it, we
can basically just scrap this. Or to be
fair, we can leave this test in um
because it's just like a standalone
test. It doesn't actually get called by
anything. We might leave this test in
because I plan on doing a couple
architecture things with neural MMO and
we might have to build um a few more
versions before we get it simple.
Voids in 40
voids would be fun.
We can get a 100,000 puffer fish
swimming around. That'd be great.
You're going to be right on time with 40
as well.
in and a big
100k would be way too many. Don't listen
to me on that. More realistically, you'd
probably end up with um any like from
one to 4K per environment instance
maximum
just because of how training goes. You
could deploy it with 100K.
You could train with 1K, deploy with
100K. It would work.
They're so cramped.
Yeah, well, you train whatever you feel
like, you know.
learn some stuff. See if you can turn it
into a cool end.
Can't wait to tie constellation.
Got to see the stars.
I'm really proud of Constellation. It's
nice.
Um,
okay. This does actually integrate both.
So, it doesn't have the GPU weights in
it yet.
Okay, that's fine. It's partway through.
It's got the CPU net added in here and
it just needs to add the GPU net and
then it needs to check the two of them
and we'll be good.
Oh, for [ __ ] sake. Why are we
rendering [ __ ] [ __ ] off, man. Why are
we rendering [ __ ]
And this model's pretty [ __ ] stupid,
I will say.
And this is what happens when it's just
like we write for loops around language
model.
I was trying Gemini today. plasma does
just cuz I'm sick of giving anthropic
money.
I really hate that um Codeex literally
doesn't have a manually accept changes
mode. It's pure vibe code. Like flop.
I don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
Um,
This is cool. We could learn this with
Puffer for sure.
didn't have to.
Yeah.
I mean, I think of all the the only
thing with um Claude is like of all of
the companies, that's kind of the one I
least want to give money to.
And it's not 20 bucks a month either. I
spent like over 2k on credits
um with puffer 4.
I'm giving this thing five minutes and
if it's still being stupid then we'll
try it with codeex just to Okay.
interesting.
I'm going to let it do this, but I
don't. That's a little sketchy to me.
You can't steer it. It just completely
[ __ ] ignores you.
See? And now it's done. Nope. We're done
with that.
Complete worthless piece of [ __ ]
I will uh not be using that. We will
delete the API tokens and everything.
worthless.
Good job, Google. Well worth however
many billion you spent.
brainstorming. None of the models are
good for brainstorming. They're all
stupid.
It can't if it can't even follow
instructions on a very basic refactor
test. Like I've told it exactly what to
do. You'll port the build over to a
standalone for the C and the CUDA. You
write tests on the loaded weights to
make sure that they're both loaded the
same. You test the activations to make
sure the same. you test the outputs that
to make sure the same.
I'm not doing it manually because it
would take me a few hours to do that.
Um, it's just a lot of fiddly [ __ ] but
like there's nothing remotely
complicated in there.
Yeah. See, now it's fixed. It just
introduced a horrid bug
for no reason.
Oh, it's actually not going to be able
to do this dip, is it?
Well, we have to go back to Claude,
which sucks.
Stupid
puffer ocean or just an ocean? There is
no more puffer li plasma.
You have an old version.
There's no
You have an old version. There's no ocean in here. You see
the latest structure. It's very very
flat and simple. Looks
vendor harness.
Um, so the problem with codeex is it
doesn't even work. Like it straight up
just doesn't work. The thing is broken.
It can't edit any files.
And I'm not going to put it on like, oh,
you access everything when it doesn't
even have an approval for Anything?
open code.
Uh, I suppose I could do that, but I'm
not going to like [ __ ] with all the
different models for now. We'll just use
this for now.
Open code. You also there's not even an
approvals by default. You have to go
like edit a random config file to even
give it an approval mode.
which kind of just tells you how dumb
their users are.
Codex just goes, "Well, I just went and
changed 20 files." Yucky yucky.
Yeah, the open code one is at least
better.
And see, I don't like that it just
randomly stops processing your requests.
start on a couple things time.
I'm going to switch the default
branches.
doing stuff now so I don't forget to do
it later.
All right. Don't switch the website yet.
Website will take a little longer to
switch.
see what else I said I have to do today.
Spencer's PR is merged.
Experiments and constellation.
Uh I can go pull the drone M real quick
while I'm waiting for this.
X chat's dropping half my messages.
H I wonder if software going to [ __ ] had
anything to do with all the LLM code
lately.
Nah,
people wouldn't do
People wouldn't do that. Surely.
Uh, LinkedIn is such a [ __ ] show.
I just don't use it anymore.
right. Do we think that the drone en is
any good?
Realistically, if I looked hard enough,
there probably several companies that
are spending a bunch of money on things
that we could do with our Lway better.
Local builds, draft some tweets,
finalized trailer.
Let's draft some tweets.
Where's the like the pro like the pro
draft thing?
Well, let me just make sure I don't
[ __ ] forget and hit post.
So, I mean, Spencer said that I know
this thing is a meme.
Only question is do we cut that thing at
the start?
I finished the code first.
That much time.
Well, that was a dumb thing.
Yeah, we probably should just have that
done automatically for us then.
Let's do uh 300 FPS. What do you guys
think?
This is running locally in C
pure C
on the CPU,
which should be pretty obvious for me
saying it's pure C, but it's not cody.
Got the Jukes. Got the Jukes.
That was a nice move. Oh, it knows it
knows the wall trap.
You got a healing herb on you. Use it,
man.
Okay, it knew that it wouldn't take
damage from the level one. Interesting.
And it doesn't use it. Should you using
the Arab now? Now,
see like it shouldn't have taken either
of those sword hits.
or that
wouldn't be taking hits. Okay, that was
good, but then it loses.
Any uni labs doing RL in puffer? We
briefly did a thing for Kathy Woo's lab.
Um, I've heard like several other people
saying, "Oh, you know, we're thinking
about it for our stuff or whatever, but
we don't have other like formal lab
collaborations at the moment.
Come on. You can kill this. Wait, you
can cheese the level. Oh, look at the
cheese,
dude. It just cheesed a level. Uh [ __ ]
that was really freaking good.
That cheesed a super high level right
there.
just trying to buy stuff or sell stuff.
It doesn't realize there aren't other
agents.
I don't know why this one doesn't eval
nicely.
No,
that sounds like some undergrad [ __ ]
I don't know. MIT, it's just like it
gets too cold there to be an undergrad,
you know?
Like at least at Stanford you could come
back from a party in the middle of the
night and not have a chance of freezing
to
Uh, I bet we have like three of these
stacked up.
snowed in in 2013.
[ __ ] all January.
I think I remember those storms
actually.
Yeah, I do
cuz I was in Connecticut and we also got
hit then.
Like three plus feet of snow, right?
Like four feet of snow almost for us
all at once.
didn't leave for 4 days.
Yeah.
Dude, why is this so [ __ ] slow?
What is this [ __ ] viewing.
I swear if it's this
Oh, this is fine.
right. I have absolutely no [ __ ] idea
what this thing thinks it's doing.
Um, so let's
let's see if we can figure it out.
Okay, so it's it just introduced a
terrible bug. Lovely.
And my terminal's broken.
Also lovely.
Okay, that's much better.
8.7
What's the end goal here? Releases uh in
two days. So, currently I'm just porting
um a demo over to make sure that the
CUDA model matches the C model because
this is going to go on the website.
And then we will see from there.
So, we let this run for a little bit. We
make sure these match. We undo all that
crap. And we are set with this model.
6.6 6.67. Yep, it matches.
We win.
This means we win.
took a couple hours.
Not always the uh the best use of time,
but not terrible.
Um,
maybe not.
What have you missed? We got neural MMO
running in C matching the original
baseline. So, we get to deploy the one
trillion model to the web. The one
trillion OBS model can be on the web.
That's going to be nice.
I need to get up and get myself some
coffee and stuff and then um
I'm trying to think how I allocate time
for the rest of the day for the release.
Yeah. Let me just start I'll just
basically get the puffer 4 box. We'll
just start training some policies
and integrating them bit by bit. I think
that's the most important thing.
So, we have all the demos done.
>> Yeah, just you should have just said
it's really [ __ ] That would have been
the quicker version of that. I'll be
right back.
Man, that was so close to 225 for 10.
Nine reps.
I needed to get it one inch higher and I
would have had it.
Uh,
let me see. Can I do that?
I don't know if there's an easy way for
me to do that quickly. Jess,
Annoying.
Here's what we can do.
That'll be easy enough to do.
That should go live in a minute or so.
If I get two for 10,
what's two for 10?
If I get this clean.
Oh, that's actually my goal.
So, I would just have to do a peeking
phase to get that.
That'd be pretty cool.
And what? It's probably like 45 12. Oh,
that's actually more than I need. Cool.
That's good to know.
here. It's going to be a little bit of a
process, I think, to do this.
Invert post some cool tech and a [ __ ] of
a lot of politics.
on using AI agents for coding.
It depends what for. [ __ ] I'm not going
through this [ __ ] again.
If you can't see, like
this stuff is like just really easy
pre-release cleanup crap.
Oh, wait. It's way easier to just do
this [ __ ] over get in the cell.
Uh, no actually coder it technically
gets rewarded for more jiggle because of
entropy.
It's just a quirk of common training.
It does have a pretty big action skip on
it though for Pong.
Hang on. Let me let me respond to this
thing. John
Just got back home. Working on training
for fight caves.
Currently hitting a wall at 30. Agent
isn't praying.
NPC ID and damage type.
Is it praying before that?
Like it should be learning to pray way
before that.
And man, I've done enough fire capes.
Like, I know how the fire caves work.
I got my pure um
I got my pur cape.
It's not that hard.
But the thing is, if it's not learning
to pray early,
that would probably be the issue. It
should be learning to pray very early
on. You'll have issues with it like
running out of prayer later in the
waves,
but you should not have issues before
that.
Got to fix replay for sure.
It should just be able to like puff or
eval it.
Uh something is wrong here.
The cost is supposed to be 24.
That's a shitty fix.
But let me try this.
Yeah. So, Enduro has a long eval. That's
fine.
This will go.
Where do we put this?
This is
right here. What we're going to grab
We'll redo the pong breakout and um
cartpole models as well as well.
That's hilarious.
It's a climbing game where you get
chased by a That's so funny.
A short indie climb again where you run
away from a centipede.
It's probably procedural and infinite.
That's so funny.
Is there a button to select the best
sweep? Anything that you right click,
it'll copy the hypers to your clipboard.
So you actually can just like look
around and see whatever you want because
there's no one best run, right? It's a
function of compute and time and all of
that.
other tiny sweeping. Yes, it's doing
G2048. I have not pulled it recently.
Uh let me go do that real quick so we
can see if it's got any nice new stuff
for us.
Why is it not Am I doing something
stupid?
No, this is what I always do. Why is it
not copying?
man. I don't know what happened,
Spencer. We had way better scores on
2048 before.
We didn't need um custom encoder or
anything.
Maybe I was normalizing the data or
something. I don't remember.
Well, it's definitely not a model
problem though cuz like
or a puffer problem in the sense like
cuz we're wrecking grid and everything.
Hang on. Let me make sure I actually got
everything.
Oh, I didn't cash it.
I'm an idiot.
Hang on.
Let me not be stupid.
See, this is why I need a break cuz I'm
starting to just not
function. And as I say that, I just slam
my glass desk.
Nice.
Right.
Oh, okay. That's better. Yo, Spencer,
look at this.
But we have to either go find the
checkpoint that corresponds to this now
annoyingly either with like a little
script
or we have to rerun it.
We could actually, now that I'm thinking
about it, man, we could just go pull all
the checkpoints
from the uh the experiments instead of
having to rerun them. It is good to
verify they work though.
So yeah, 14K is way better. This is post
environment fixes. So,
and you can see that it actually is
scaling well with compute. Like
potentially we could even get this
higher with more compute.
Yeah, I think 14K is good.
me. Make sure we still have this demo
working.
Do we want to reclaim the uh the 2048
box for more sweeps? Spencer, what else
do we need to run?
Rareware
messing with go to fix a bug.
I can run hardware.
Oh, that's your sweep. Let's not [ __ ]
with that.
is ready to go, right? Um, apparently
not.
Pac-Man
lime volley.
That's a nice clean point right there.
Grab this one.
Then we just gigas solve everything.
You don't need this crap at the top
anymore as well.
Default.
What music do I'm literally Look, this
is the dumbest [ __ ] ever. I'm literally
looping this one track from Sea of Stars
uh on repeat.
Let's do this one.
I think this one's a little unstable.
Here, I've also got Where's my one of my
favorite hard style tracks?
Oh yeah, this is the other one that I
will uh
but that's more of a progressive track.
So, me
What's wrong with this lamb volley and
like
No, I wouldn't have actually. Different
path.
The eval are weird
for slime volley. It like it looks good
in training and then the final eval it
changes a bunch.
very good. Oh yeah, and it doesn't seg
fold anymore. You put some work in on
this one. Thank you.
All right, we'll see if this [ __ ] up or
not.
Uh we won't be able to push a new one of
these to the website anyways.
So, let me just pull something that's
like relatively quick.
Like this one, maybe.
Um,
yeah, let's just do something like this.
What's the curriculum thing for
Terraform, Spencer? That's not easy to
enable, right? Like, we probably
shouldn't [ __ ] with that today.
Tetris. Ah, [ __ ]
Tetris takes forever.
uh let's pick something
scale
follow you from deep learning with the S
scene.
Very interesting chat.
Yeah, that was fun.
There's uh been so much progress since
then as well. The project moves quite
quickly.
We're doing final benchmarks for the uh
the release the start of the week.
It's a worthy
a worthy new release. Worthy 40.
I'm exhausted. This is the end of an
eighth month eightmon grind here.
I'll be following. Thank you. Don't
forget to star the puffer on GitHub. It
helps us out a lot.
You'll see in just a couple days all the
new stuff.
having to write lots of things over
since I've taken shortcuts with my
pretense of making things simpler for
the agents. Yeah,
that happens. Vault,
that happens.
Um, I'm going to have fun taking a look
at that with you soon. As you can tell,
I am out of steam, though. Spec action,
automatically equip the weapon and
attacking gear actions.
Yeah, that type of stuff makes sense.
Action space will be a bit of a pain
with
We want to lead the agent somehow.
Wait, we can.
Well, you definitely need the game
engine correct. And then uh what stuff
needs to be scaffolded will be a matter
of experimentation.
But I can tell you for sure that you
want to make those decisions with the
benefit of um a stable build, a good
hyper pram sweep, etc., etc., after I've
looked at it.
Oh yeah. Did you try just having it beat
Zuck? Was that a thing that works?
cuz I I do not believe that it can't
just learn to go sit behind the shield.
It will totally learn to walk with the
shield like instantly if it's
implemented correctly.
refactoring a lot sounds good. You're
going to have a little bit of time, man,
cuz I'm not going to like I'm not going
to launch it and then be like, "All
right, time for the environment." I'm
going to launch it and then just be like
for the next several days.
Wave 50.
No, 50 is good.
50 is good progress.
Uh-oh.
I'm in danger.
I don't know why the [ __ ] it's doing
that, but sure.
Okay. 0.9 PF.
We'll get 0.9 something perf.
Okay, we're almost done here. This is
quick. These last two were quick.
Triple tried. Not super quick, but no
big deal.
So this is like we'll comfortably have
all our models.
That sounds awful. Why would you do
that?
Uh, we can get one of the fancy ones
here. They're pretty quick.
That's an obnoxiously big triple triad
policy.
and that is everything except
2048.
could ship this one
12K score to the website.
But this one is pretty cool.
But this one won't load quickly, will
it?
Let me see.
Maybe it will.
It is.
Oh, no. That's way too big.
We'll chip this one.
This is cool cuz this one is straight
capacity limit.
Oh, this is a decent little policy.
We're getting 16k
It'll remember that it doesn't need the
weight sizes.
Uh that's 32K right there. So we're
getting some 32Ks.
Okay. Couple M's kind of chunky.
Mostly the ones you'd expect.
You're not really interested in
every last bit of perf out of M's, are
you?
What do you mean? The alpha star type
shed.
Have you seen that policy? That policy
is just like conv encoder for 2D,
attention encoder for attentional.
Oh, I guess there's some feature end
stuff.
I mean, the thing is it depends on
it really depends. Vault, I'd say that
people tend to overdo it more than they
underdo it.
like for instance right now we're
bottlenecking neural MMO because of the
custom encoder
maximize the perf of a given end.
Um
it depends what you mean by that right
because like doing domain specific
feature engineering unless it is to
inform you of something more practical
that doesn't actually push the research
forward
and I think that puffer has gotten good
enough that like we're going to be able
to full solve the inferno cleanly
without That
like for instance, right, we just beat
we just beat like five domain specific
encoders that we'd used on different
projects that were a good couple
thousand lines of code to maintain and
like took a lot of work. We just beat
them with the new architecture without
anything custom.
Okay. Yeah, exactly. Vault.
So, a lot of it's just not as needed.
It's kind of nice that now we get to
finally see the work pay off. We get to
watch all the superhuman policies.
Like look at this stupid thing. I can't
do this.
Well, they killed the field and most of
those teams got laid off
and now the field is [ __ ] because of
it.
And if I weren't building Puffer, it
would just stay 2K steps per second
probably for another decade.
There's 4096.
Pretty cool.
Collecting paychecks. Well, I mean, I
could have done that if I'd wanted to,
right? I could have very easily gone and
picked whatever lab.
Oh, why didn't he eat the ghost?
The ghost, man.
Pretty good Pac-Man agent. That's better
than me at the game for sure.
It doesn't know what to do, though.
It wants those dots down there.
Kind of stuck.
Lives forever though.
Okay, it's a good policy. The eval was
just kind of screwy.
Was completely unfair.
Uh, get good scrub.
It's okay. I can't score a single point
on it either.
Okay, they're doing it. They're just not
great.
I don't know if it would be harder than
no pillar vault. I think it's just like
a different type of thing. I think like
um probably like one of the guys is a
really good street fighter could do it
or something, you know.
It looked like the policy had it solved.
Oh, and slime. No, actually there are
better policies than that. Funny enough,
there is a cheese you can do that's like
unwinable against,
but it's like this really tight trick
that you have to learn.
Inferno agents rather keep walking under
melee shuffle.
That's fine, Vault.
Like if that's what they want to do,
that's totally fine.
They're going to have to learn how to
step under, like to step out from under
it without getting hit, though. Or
they're going to have to flick um prey
melee on the way out.
Both of those are reasonable.
Honestly, the only type of stuff I'm
worried about is it like not realizing
how to not you like overuse supplies
early. Stuff like that I think would be
harder. But like even then I think it'll
just learn to one tick flick from that
if it's possible in this base. It'll
learn prayer preservation based on like
running out at the end most likely.
Let's check the rest of them in the
meantime. I don't know why I'm delaying.
Look at the puffer.
You can actually this one you can just
play.
If I just hold down the key,
do I catch up? No, it wrecks me.
It randomly traps something. Standing 15
away. It looks like it doesn't notice.
Merl MMO right here.
Get tool. Equip spade. Get armor.
Healing leaf.
Use the damn leaf, my guy. Okay. Helm.
No sword. All right. That's the wrong
tier. Gem. Yeah. Lots of healing items.
Use one of them. Yeah, there you go.
Come on. Right here. That's
kind of funny.
Minecraft.
Um, it's nowhere near as useful of an
Envis Runescape vault and it's a pain to
make fast
Doesn't look like a 99. Oh, wait. No,
this is a max size maze.
This is literally the hardest possible
thing.
Well, fixed rewards is a bad like that
makes you think that it's a like
algorithm problem. It's there's no fixed
incentives. The game doesn't have good
incentives at all. It's a sandbox. You
just kind of do stuff.
I can't do non-divisible by 64 horizons
in
uh if you can't that's a bug Spencer.
there.
We got policies for everything but drone
as well.
Okay, this works.
Try on drive
mini batch to
Oh, um, there's supposed to be a
fallback for that, Spencer. It might not
work. I It might be like divisible by
four or something.
I'd have to look at it.
What do you think about Tiny Red and the
guy? Tiny Redd's cool.
A little bit of craziness with it. Um,
as far as Pure Python stuff goes though,
it's a very cool project.
They're doing some really cool things.
hell of a lot better than um a lot of
what I see with Jacks.
I don't like everything about what
they're doing, but good project.
should solve purpose anyways. Yep,
that'll work. Spencer.
Okay, this is it. So, as expected,
it's um the actions.
Roll Australia. I got to do a couple
sets as well. Got to get my benching in.
I want to finish this first.
Um, we have a little bit of like defense
adjacent stuff in this, but there's kind
of a certification process for that. So,
you don't get like government like
government people going directly to you.
Um, if we wanted to do that type of
stuff, we would probably roll out like a
subsidiary to do That
There it is. That's actually going to be
it.
bots raid in your chat.
I get so many of them from Twitch, it's
not even worth me bothering.
Twitch just needs to fix their [ __ ]
It's like 10 a day.
It could be a real field, but it's
mostly a meme.
There's a restroom and get us that in
real quick.
Well, this builds
Tower climb.
Did I not do tower climb?
Tower climb in here.
Go get that.
Uh, it lags with the file browser
sometimes.
I don't know why.
Why is maze not here?
There it is.
one. Not load
or is it just chunky?
I got like 10 minutes and then I got to
get ready. I got to go for dinner
and I'll be back afterwards to finalize
stuff.
man. I'm so tired. We also have Hang on.
If you just go like this,
there's a beta tab that has the um
instructions here if you want to test
stuff. I still have to ship the Docker,
so I have to actually do that tonight as
well. Ship the docker.
installation's less scary than 300.
How's this? Or this?
But realistically, this is easier. The
Docker.
Now I'm just do Yeah, Docker will just
Mark.
Very nice. I have a bluebird
making a nest in the bluebird box
20 ft outside of my uh window.
That's very nice.
This is what keeps me sane. I literally
have a bluebird here in a storm of
flower petals
uh from the trees. Yes.
the announcement's Monday, not Sunday.
Sunday is a terrible day to um announce
[ __ ]
It will technically be up on Sunday. The
only thing there's one link that I'm not
going to update until um Monday.
Everything else will be up and then the
articles start going up on Monday.
Oh, I think I should go for uh dinner in
a second here. Anyways, but for the
folks who've been watching, I will be
back after dinner streaming. Um,
first RLN
solid. Um, yeah, for the folks watching
Puffer.ai Say hi for all the things. We
got the beta docks up. Sorry the puffer
fish. It really helps.
And I will be back in less than an hour.
And we will ship um we'll ship all the
new end builds. You can play around with
the new policies,
make whatever tweaks. We'll probably see
if we can get a Docker build. We'll fix
constellation and all that.
And uh you will be able to exclusive for
people here because the link won't be on
the site but the file will be there.
You'll be able to play with
constellation in your browser as well.
Pretty cool.